welcome to this video bling Cody SF
probably the way to pronounce that but
it's a French flag okay so we got a
king's indian i'm going to play h3
Bishop g5 that's a line I recently
learned that I recently looked at it big
with a student of mine and it's
something that I also recommended in
this old rep it to our series of mine
the deform repertoire and it's still a
good line it just kind of yeah sometimes
you lose side of singing of things yeah
you play something and you think it's
quite good and then you try out
something else and then did you remember
wait why am why do they play this one in
the first place was there a reason for
it and then you're kind of recognized
hmm there was no real reason it's just
um kind of hmm I don't know slipped
slipped off the radar okay plate takes
him some time here the early age six is
normally something that white welcomes
because the pawn might get a target with
22 for example gaining a move or
sometimes the light squares are ya a
weakness so yeah so you have Bishop d3
on on 93 and playing Bishop d3 putting
the bishop on c2 yeah night h5 why black
is trying to force force them at five
move in this case I can play g3 as well
yeah let's just play g3 and prevent f5
probably will play it anyway as usual
but it looks like it shouldn't work here
with bishop on d3 and the Queen on d1 c5
uncommon combination of moves playing
night a six and then c5 okay so I wonder
what about Knight f3 here is this this
is ok on how do I play this in the first
place or Bishop b2 pushing the night
back maybe the bishop on d3 is not badly
place but I can go for that him and
develop now won't be easy if I'm to play
a 5 absolutely not so go back
I'm a bit mystified what black is doing
is he going for the b5 or f5 stuff ok I
played you for here
to be 6 Quincy to all night before and
then a high F up this is my idea okay
also I absolutely don't mind to trade
queens of course where it is h5 to force
or provoke g5 which is as usual very
nice and wide it's a very strangely
played game so I want to kick this
annoyed probably have to start with a 3
I know that I don't threaten it really
no he goes back what kind of the count
is that let me check that it's got 7,000
games so it's probably not a computer it
looks a little bit like a computer game
because it's just I don't really get to
get this shuffling some of the moves
rookie 88 and stuff it looks kind of
kind of mystifying okay so let's see i
have from queenside ideas before would
love to trade the light squared Bishop
and get the Knight to f5 let's let's get
one night to g3 first and then see what
we can do I can also just play before
maybe I should do that this threatens to
be pawn yeah I think I should do that
I've got everything covered them so I
can go before and just threaten to take
on c5 and take one of the be pawns okay
does it like that
and take andrew p6 it's not not
particularly bad but i know i'm not sure
piling up on the B file doesn't really
make that much sense
grah Alfred math course not let's see
how to do that don't really see how to
if I don't see to empower see how to
improve at the moment maybe I should
have taken actually maybe I should have
taken that's not so not so easy I would
like to trade the light squared Bishop
but I don't see how I wonder if a four
is a move a 45 I guess I should take
that on I should take on c5 in the first
place it's difficult to get get
something done without that so let's
take it
so tiling up there but still it's not
easy to make any headway a4 a5 I can go
over here came to a to covering the a
pawn maybe I should play night maybe
night be five is in fact an idea and not
really am but maybe maybe 95 the
situation where when he has to if it
takes I'm I'm very very ok it doesn't ok
we get this night over to see three I
don't really have to guard the f5 square
time morning
maybe a four a five again maybe I can
get this in okay 352 and so on for later
a5 only thing that's not not working
okay let's go back to cover like that
okay
it's not so easy to actually win still
it's nice as it looks we went on time
but that's not a time when I mean white
is just completely in control so it just
takes takes a 15 X and how just takes a
while but at the end i will get in 85
and this is just it's just sitting there
in his bad position yeah i mean that
cell hair awesome to marry if my
unexpected moves unless quickly a queen
bee 6 and rook e8 and through d8 its
kind of mysterious well okay that's not
its he's not a computerized it's it's a
7,000 7,000 game account so so no one
cheating going on yeah this kind of
position is just very comfortable why it
has all the space as it's quite quite
typical if queens are traded in the
Kings Indian um yeah not not not in
every position but in those kind of
space advantage positions um Queen trade
is normally favoring white who's got
more space and um yeah well usually you
don't want to trade that much if you are
the one with more space but here we have
the situation where white is expanded
very much and this can leave as king
vulnerable and the Queen trade is very
very okay here for white yeah this some
structures is very nice and very
one-sided just not completely clear how
I actually should win it I think I
probably could have gotten in before
before earlier I have to play it with
before I think otherwise I don't get the
position opened this this was I think I
think I'm okay all of all of the all the
way always always kept kept
big big edge no system is lagging a lot
oops yeah I mean if we look at the final
position I think I got more earlier but
this is still very nice if we think
about this let's say pc cannot do much
more than then shuffle and let's see how
am I going to play let's say I'm
preparing to the utmost I'm going to a
good 91 I guess if he takes hear ya i'm
checking with the poignant i got 90 or
to f5 so this is not possible he's going
something like nothing right here
nothing and a five this is this is what
I'm but I'm going for cheeks let's say
we trade on everything here this kind of
this kind of position it's very
difficult for black to to hold yeah I
have a huge space advantage d6 is weak
f5 is weak the ship will come here and
I'm going to invade with the king while
he has absolutely zero come to play lets
me has some chances to hold this but I
think there they are relatively slim the
comp is on plus 1 point 6 which is yeah
I mean it's more assuring than it then
it's showing 0 but another idea by the
way is said bishop that's important
really it's bishop to a form that's a
Romero Bishop to a 4 and maybe get those
traded so that I can ultimately sink in
the Knight to f5 if I get an
unchallenged lied to f5 this would be a
disaster at d 6 & age six a week yeah I
was nice okay well thanks for watching